the video that showed the world the last
moments of george floyd's life
was recorded by a young woman bystander
she herself was filmed by one of the
police officers body cameras
in the blue next to her young cousin in
green
now 18 she came to give evidence not
identified by the cameras in court
and only by her first name darnella
there's a little girl in the green shirt
and there you are do you see you
yes images from cctv show how she made
sure her cousin
was inside the store before going back
to begin filming
i see a man on the ground terrified
scared
begging for his life it seemed like
he knew it seemed like he knew it was
over for him
uh did you ever see him trying to
administer cpr
no uh did you see him call anyone else
to administer aid to mr floyd
no did he call out and ask if anybody
amongst the bystanders knew cpr who
might be able to help
not at all these were her final words to
the jury
it's been nights i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting
and not saving his
life where it all happened is now a
shrine to george floyd
as the reckoning over his death
continues in court another of those
bystanders donald williams
told the court he called emergency
services to report what was happening
at some point um did you make a 9-1-1
call
that is correct uh did call the police
on the police
and why did you do that because
i believe i witnessed a murder that call
was played in court he just pretty much
just killed this guy
that wasn't resisting arrest he had his
knee on the dude neck the whole time
to someone on the scene mr williams said
this
murderers
derek chauvin denies murder and
manslaughter he says drugs and ill
health killed george floyd
bro what the jury's heard so far
is from those who see this very
differently greg milam sky news
minneapolis